sentiment  yes definitely i mean uh it also reminds  me of some of these vienna pawn  sacrifices but both sides have one extra  move the pawn black spawn is on c6 and  white's pawn is on a4 otherwise  everything looks very very similar then  knight xf7 king f7 bishop tx66 wow i  mean  that's two minor p sacrifice we've got  to look at some lines okay first  question what happens if black gets  greedy captures the other other bishop  queen to e6 queen to b3 check king d6 is  impossible because bishop g3 loses on  the spot so the king will have to march  all the way to f5 let's just show that  uh king b6 bishop g3 looks like disaster  yeah very interesting moment queen g6  means it's just game on and queen beat  three the play zone immediately stops  the game  ah queen beast it's yeah and it's  stopped yeah queen beastly check wow i  mean okay it was very interesting uh  maybe the whole bluff  consisted of the fact that it looked  dangerous